i'm sure you want to talk good things
about your country because that's what
you're paid to do
every question you have asked so far you
have gone straight
into the negative dimension is
bangladesh in the habit of giving
pardons
to convicted murderers the certainty
with which you are speaking
in many ways is surprising me for years
now the government of bangladesh has
been criticized around the world for its
human rights record
but its reputation received another jolt
this month with the release of a new
documentary
alleging high-level bribery and
corruption my guest this week from dhaka
is gauhar rizvi foreign affairs adviser
to the country's prime minister
when will the authorities stop denying
the truth about the repression they've
inflicted
and clean up their act
welcome to conflict zone thank you your
country has become
a byword for egregious human rights
abuses which your government routinely
denies as an academic who's used to
dealing
in truth why do you serve a government
that seems to have so little regard for
that commodity
mr sebastian i think this question needs
to be qualified a bit
uh when you say of egregious uh
human rights violations might i
uh explain that human
human rights is a very large
uh world well let me be more specific
then let me be more specific arbitrary
detention
torture enforced disappearances
extrajudicial executions
all of which your government is accused
of by the un human rights
groups throughout asia human rights
watch amnesty international
the committee against torture that's
what i had in mind
well i i wish i could accept
these uh allegations in its entirety
i will not be denying that there have
not been instances
of uh some uh disappear
some disappearances uh
when you talk about uh torture
there is no documented evidence of uh
torture
to the best of my uh uh knowledge
the un committee against torture is
certain that it's carried out
routinely it's received report after
report that it's carried out routinely
by your security forces and you would
you would have us believe that they've
all got it wrong and where bangladesh is
concerned
i would not i would not deny it and i
would not say that they have
i will get it wrong but i do also want
to say
that as far as the government
is concerned torture
is illegal and we try to make sure
that torture doesn't take place you know
why i was objecting
to the way you uh posed the question mr
sebastian
is because so many good things have
happened in bangladesh
today bangladesh is one of the
spectacular successes
of development yes and you're very good
at
promoting um the successes the economic
is for instance of your country
but that's not what i'm asking you about
i'm not what i'm asking you about
i'm asking you about the things that
have gone wrong in your country
um your government for instance claims
zero tolerance
of corruption well the boss of
transparency international in bangladesh
himself summed up the extent of
corruption
when he accused the government of going
after only what he called
the small fish the activities of corrupt
leaders at the top are beyond our
imagination he said we don't see robust
investigation or effective legal action
against any of those big players so so
much for the
the promise of zero tolerance for
corruption
okay if you if you recall
about six to nine months ago there was a
uh a big action
against various corrupt individuals
and organizations many of them have been
arrested
police investigation is taking place
uh the anti-corruption commission is
inquiring into it
you know at the end of the day we have
to follow a judicial
uh process and this is a time consuming
uh process i am not saying our process
is perfect i am not saying that there
isn't sometimes
a political uh considerations also go
into it
these things are true but where i object
and mr sebastian you are such an
experienced uh
journalist is that
the way you paint the picture it's also
one-sided
that you your viewers may end up getting
the wrong
impression well it's not it's not me
painting the picture i'm relying on
reports for internationally respected
organizations like human rights watch
amnesty international the committee
against
that in that case please allow me
to uh balance that picture with the
reality as it happens on the ground
yes which which which you are doing but
but all this has paved the way for a
high-profile documentary
which was released this month by the al
jazeera network
which alleged shocking levels of
corruption
among senior officials of your state and
your government's immediate reaction
was to brand the film false defamatory
and the smear you didn't even bother to
investigate first that's not the
response of an honest government is it
uh inquiry is taking place
it is being inquired but let me really
with all sincerity i ask you
the title of that documentary was all
the prime minister's men
and we were told that it would expose
corruption around the prime minister
do you really believe that documentary
succeeded in doing that was there
a single evidence which incriminated the
prime minister
in the alleged uh uh corruption
i mean this this is where i think as
sensible
academics and journalists we should
stand back
and ask ourselves what was the evidence
given to incriminate the prime
minister's involvement
and yet this whole documentary was built
as to show how corrupt the regime is
dr rizvi yes doctor is looking looking
at the film which was produced by al
jazeera
here was a television team that was able
to locate
two high-level fugitives from justice
convicted of murder
whose elder brother just happens to be
your serving chief
of the army general aziz ahmed um
apparently your own law enforcement
couldn't find his uh
brothers who were on the run but but
they did that's pretty embarrassing for
you isn't it
certainly it is but on the other hand
again
i'm not going to be defending everything
but the way you are putting the question
to me
i i feel almost it is necessary
should a person be judged guilty
because of the guilt of his brothers i
think this is a question we need to ask
now if the brother has helped his
uh if the uh the brother in uh
the armed forces helped his brothers to
evade justice to uh avoid
uh uh or further his criminal activities
this accusation would be extremely
extremely uh uh valid
what happened was long long before this
gentleman
uh uh became the army army chief
all right well let's just let's just
look at some of the details which came
out in the film
about about the general general ahmed's
brothers
two of them anis and harris were found
guilty of involvement in the 1996 murder
of a member of a rival party and both
absconded from justice and went on the
run
now third brother joseph was also
convicted and spent more than 10 years
on death row magically just before his
brother aziz was promoted to head of the
army
joseph gets a presidential pardon how
did that happen
is bangladesh in the habit of giving
pardons to convicted murderers
who gunned down their opponents on the
street in cold blood
is that what you do you give them a
presidential part
mr sebastian the the certainty with
which you are speaking
in many ways is surprising me and you
have linked
the appointment of uh the army chief
and his brother's release uh into
one uh story let me remind you it is one
story doctor
no no no no no mr sebastian let me my
point is you have to be pretty well
connected to get a pardon for cold blood
let me give you the facts then you draw
your conclusion
please let me give you the facts the
the brother in question had served
about 20 years in prison
there is a a law
in the country that after serving a
certain amount of
years you may be given parole
or clemency uh by the president now
all this happened long before months and
months before
even the uh the vacancy to which the
brother was appointed to receive a rose
it happened completely separately this
man has served
35 years plus in the armed forces worked
his way up
uh with a fairly clean
record so why should we malign
and link link these two stories together
i would like you to look at the time i
would like you to look at the
timeline of the two events these are
six months apart all right oh okay dr
rizvi
the the point is also which the film
brought out is that
your army chief knew perfectly well
where his two other brothers were the
ones that were on the run
and apparently didn't tell the relevant
authorities isn't that worth
investigating
it would be worth investigating but
please also
you know as much as i do both these
gentlemen
were outside the jurisdiction of
bangladesh
and yes if this information had been
available
we would have tried to have extracted
extradited them and provided we had an
extradition treaty
with these two countries in fact in many
cases we have done
and there is no reason to believe that
we would not have done and you are quite
right
that if this information had been
available to the government
the government would have taken uh
action
well perhaps this is all just too close
to the higher echelons of power too
dangerous to delve into
isn't the fact that nobody in your
country wants to delve too deeply into
suspicions of high-level corruption do
they
too many people disappear and end up
dead if they say the wrong thing and ask
the wrong questions don't they
it's fact of life in your country no no
no
mr sebastian uh we
we are proud however is perfect
we are proud of our liberal democratic
system
we are proud that we have a prime
minister
who has uh uh
uh high uh very low
intolerance or of corruption
our armed forces are firmly under
civil control and and therefore
to say that uh corruption
uh is connected at the high level well
how is it
how is it how is it then that in a state
which is supposed to have a functioning
justice system
that these two fugitive brothers of your
army chief anis and harris convicted
murderers
actually are reported to have returned
to dhaka in broad daylight in 2019
to celebrate a family wedding there
aren't many fugitive killers who can
show up in a big society wedding mingle
with the president
and foreign dignitaries unless they have
protection right at the top you know
that as well as i do
i we we are both you are absolutely
right
if it was known to anyone that
these gentlemen have uh returned to
bangladesh
uh immediately
they would have been apprehended there
is no
uh question about it but they were
pictured at the wedding dr risley
let us an army military club
two convicted murderers uncles of the
bridegroom happily celebrating with
everyone else
we are telescoping something that
happened over 25 years
into a single incident
the the brothers had committed
crime in 1996
long before general aziz had even
joined the army as a cadet
we now said uh uh go forward 25 years
uh uh later and we are saying that these
two men came back to bangladesh
and if they did and as as the photograph
suggests they interest this was
absolutely a great failure
of our uh
justice administration and the uh
immigration police
in the airport there is no question
about that
but you will also have to understand
this
that these people had acquired
different passports which
unless it was known to the government
unless
that was on the watch list it is
quite easy for uh them to have slipped
in
along with thousands of other people who
come in and go out
i am not one moment suggesting that this
has not been a failing of the government
it hasn't done
dr rizwi in a democracy with the kind of
free press that you've claimed exists in
bangladesh
all these allegations from al jazeera
would be
plastered over the newspapers and the
broadcast media but they aren't are they
something that the dhaka tribune sought
to explain when it wrote to its readers
the reason for our silence it said is
simple
the current state of media and
defamation law makes it unwise for any
bangladeshi media house
to venture into any kind of meaningful
comment on the controversy that's it
isn't it you have cowed the media into
submission
and muzzled it so it's become afraid of
its own shadow are you
proud of that
if if it were uh
true as you say i would be ashamed of it
but let me tell you
what the truth is yes are you saying the
paper is lying
are you saying the newspaper's lying
let me not uh answer in yes and no
let me give you the uh explanation
indeed there is a thing called digital
security act
it is to prevent
uh violence rumors
and inciting of people through the
uh the digital platform
this law unfortunately
which our government inherited
was the ict act was passed in 1996.
our government revised it and it is now
called the
digital security act but sadly
we have now learned that some
of the wordings are very loose and vague
which leaves it open to its abuse
but to jump from there to say
that the press has been muzzled to say
that uh there is no freedom of press in
bangladesh
let me just tell you there are well
doctors
i i understand but amnesty international
said that in the first nine months of
last year
more than 800 cases were filed
under this act with the loose language
that you talk about
with many of the most prominent editors
and senior journalists
increasingly targeted 800
cases in this with using this law
which your government apparently
inherited your government doesn't seem
to have any reservations about using
this law
does it isn't it time to admit your law
is nothing but a weapon
to silence critics and suppress dissent
that's the truth of it isn't it
no i would accept your criticism and i
would have accepted your allegations
had you asked the human rights watch
of the 800 or so
uh and i'm taking your figure as you as
you gave it to me
who were invested how many of them were
journalists you know you you have used a
broad
figure of 800. how we faced a serious
terrorism uh attacks in this country
we had to fight it fight hard against
terrorism how many of those 800
were actually terrorists how many of
those 800
were criminals who incited violent
activities without differentiating you
have given me the
figure of 800. please i challenge you to
look at that figure
and tell me how many were actual
journalists and well i can
i can break i can break down some of
those figures for you because human
rights
groups are pretty much united in their
condemnation of your
government's crackdown on free speech
especially
during the current pandemic human rights
watch said you've arrested
journalists artists students doctors
political opposition members and
activists who spoke out against the
government's response to the pandemic
or otherwise criticized the ruling party
last june you even arrested a 15 year
old boy
for allegedly defaming the prime
minister on facebook
the child was sentenced to time in a
juvenile detention
center thanks let me now uh
uh answer this question uh
as as as clearly as i possibly can
you have been telling you are telling
your viewers
that during this period of pandemic the
government did all sorts of horrible
things
have you told your uh audience
that bangladesh is one of the few
countries in the world
compared to your own country in the uk
to the united states or anywhere else in
uh
in the world where we have tackled
pandemics
really well with our limited resources
we have one of the lowest death rate
in the world we have the highest rate of
recovery we have expanded our hospitals
to provide treatment none of these facts
were
mentioned you have uh picked up 15
examples
or so yes i'm i'm sure you want to
change the subject doctor
i'm sure you want to talk good things
about your country because that's what
you're paid to do
that's why you're a government that's
why you're a government advisor
but but why why why i'm asking
do you turn a blind eye to what the un
committee
against torture has been calling the
widespread
and routine commission of torture and
ill treatment
you passed an act in 2013 supposedly
outlawing torture but six years later
only 17
cases had been filed against security
personnel
and not a single one had been completed
by
six years later not one in six years had
been completed
is that a proud achievement for a
government
that allegedly is cracking down on
torture it isn't is it
it's a disgrace well let me again say
you are right in the sense when you say
that
in seven years uh x number of uh
uh cases of torture have been filed and
none of them
yes has come to a final judgment if
i i take your statement to be free and i
will agree that this is not
a very good very very good
uh uh uh record
but the truth of the matter is we did
pass along
the truth of the matter is we are trying
to deal
deal with it and where i am constantly
uh objecting uh not because you think
i'm doing this because i i and as you
said
uh i am paid uh uh to do this
i might turn the same thing to you
and say is it not right that you are
you are being paid simply to make these
attacks without
putting it into broad wide context
every question you have asked so far you
have gone straight
into the negative dimension even on
pandemic
you said very clearly that all these
horrible things
that have happened please tell me
another country in the whole wide world
which has dealt with pandemic as
effectively as our government has done
dr rizvi it's very good tactic to change
the subject but i don't want to leave it
because you said that your government is
taking action
um against the human rights abuses
is it going to take action against
members of this so-called rapid action
battalion that you have
because the the um un says
its members have been credibly alleged
to have committed torture arbitrary
arrests
unacknowledged detention disappearances
and extrajudicial killings
of people in their custody you tell me
about the good things your country has
done
but are you not embarrassed with the
actions that this
rapid action battalion has been carrying
out in the name of your government
your government is killing everything
again it's killing it
let me say with all honesty and and
humility and embarrassment that the some
of the cases that you have just
uh stated are true there have been
instances of that which nobody in the
government
uh in his or her right minds defend
but and also who's in
let me finish you have asked me a
question let me finish answering
what you did not say in your uh
question is how many of those
uh uh rapid battalion police force
have been removed from services how many
of them are under investigation
and how many of them have been charged
this was not mentioned by you
this is the role of the government that
when it finds out
that something has some egregious
violation of
human rights or law has taken place they
must get to the bottom
i don't say we are always successful but
i
do resent not being given the credit
for the efforts that we are making all
right
dr gao rizvi been good to have you on
conflict
zone thank you very much indeed
thank you mr sebastian it has been such
a pleasure
and an experience to speak to you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you